the destruction in cabo delgado's mussim
wada praya is staggering mozambique and
london troops retook this important port
town on sunday it was being used by the
armed group locally known as al-shabab
which has ties to isil as a base to
launch attacks across the province the
fighters first attacked the town in 2017
marking the beginning of the conflict in
this ruby a natural gas-rich
northernmost region of mozambique
they took control of muslim world prayer
in 2020
but people who fled their homes are now
being asked by local officials to return
frequent patrols around the town are
making that easier for some
before the soldiers came we were being
chased around like goats by al-shabaab
children were suffering in the forest
where we were hiding out now we are
coming back to civilization
taking this port town is a major victory
for the troops they say they want to
remove al-shabab from the entire
province within a month our
actions
talk more
than words
as you can see
today
we are free
we have a museum but the prior
freed
from terrorists
but
this is the first stage
the next stage
is to move forward
to go
to their
big stronghold
some analysts say the rebellion in cabo
delgado is largely motivated by
inequalities and grievances against the
state it's also believed fighters from
other parts of the continent are
involved and mozambique's historically
weak security forces were unable to deal
with the situation
so rwanda deployed about a thousand
soldiers in july to help other southern
african nations have also promised to
send a stand by force destroying those
strongholds is the initial part
but the stabilization phase is also
another phase that
we believe we will play a part
as we progress towards
the the the whole peaceful
area of caba delgado the soldiers are
strategizing their next move they say
they want to make sure all shabbat
fighters don't return the people they're
here to protect say they just want to
get on with their lives
catherine soy al jazeera